there has been any moment when you are
like totally burned out after all these
flame war they're like no I'm done I'm
done the colonel I'll go and do
something else no I'd never be burnt out
in that sense I mean I
it happens commonly that I say okay now
I mean just the last merge window was
fairly painful so there was two weeks
not just the regular work of a merge
window which is my busiest time anyway
but there were issues going on anyway
and when I finally close to merge window
I was like okay I'm gonna take a
breather but it's not like burnout kind
of breather it's more like okay it's
good I have a con week coming up I have
some travel I will just step back for a
couple of days and then I'm fine again
but you travel a lot of you don't travel
much no this was just this time I don't
travel very much for conferences but but
my point is even normally I can just say
okay I mean I'll do something else for
three days right and that's fine it's
it's not the kind where I feel like this
project is not worth it it's more like
wow okay now I just need to have an
extended weekend yeah take a break from
you know let's dress and everything
right and obviously it's not calm I mean
most of time I'm not stressed I am I
mean we have a very working code flaw
there is even when I'm busy it's seldom
really stressful it's more like okay now
I need to sit in front of the computer
from early morning to fairly late at
night but that that's the first week of
the merge window it's always like that
and that's normally not a big deal so a
couple of times a year I get the feeling
like okay that was that it was too much
let's take a few days long
you